we're gonna start with the most basic
question should founders bootstrap or
fundraise yeah and what should a founder
consider when making that decision
great so should they bootstrap or
fundraise Demont you have to deal with
this all the time because you're a
frontline when we're making that first
hundred k check in the launch
accelerator what people through the the
thinking here should you bootstrap why
should you fundraise sure I think the
first thing to that founders should
realize is that fundraising is a path
for very few startups for very few
companies in general ok most businesses
a knife are you know quote unquote
bootstrap there are lifestyle businesses
that in my style not in a negative way
but they're just businesses that don't
require fundraising and aren't aren't
businesses that gonna follow that
fundraising path and so I think one
interesting question that we often hear
VC say is the Alaska founder is this a
venture scale business and so I'm
curious you know as someone that's been
in this a long time how do you define
what a venture scale business is when
you're a founder ask that yeah and I
think there's a lot of negativity around
the word lifestyle business sure and it
we should pause for a second and just
explain what an investor means when they
say a lifestyle business they mean this
business if it succeeds or if it's
already succeeding is gonna provide
let's say the two of you had a business
a great lifestyle for the two of you it
might make five million dollars a year
have a twenty percent margin and throw
off a million dollars a year but that
business at five million if it grows ten
percent year-over-year in ten years okay
yeah maybe it's doing 12 or 15 million
and maybe it makes two or three million
dollars in profits well that makes it a
twenty or thirty million dollar
enterprise value which were an investor
means if they invested in your company
at seven million maybe they're gonna
triple their money that's not what
venture capitalist for venture
capitalists are trying to 20 30 40 50 X
their investment and angel investors
we're trying to 100x so venture scale in
my mind in 2019 means 100 million
dollars in revenue
with great margins maybe 30 40 50
percent gross margins that means the
margins have to take up the cost of
providing it now software can even be
higher than that right 80 or 90 percent
so that is the key and most people will
give us projections we see this all the
time
we're in five years they grow the
business from $300,000 in revenue in
2019 and then in five years in 2024
they're gonna be at five million dollars
right yeah and they're like this is a
huge success it's like unbelievable I
agree 10x and it's not what a venture
capitalist do what do you think what do
you think the timeframe is so what you
know if I if I'm thinking about how fast
can I grow seven years ten years a
venture capital firm would like to see
an exit in six seven eight years that's
good for them and the fun lifetime is
using ten years so on the outside ten
twelve years and in a best-case scenario
five or six years to hit 50 million 75
million a hundred million in revenue